Suppose I know something about the
motion, the, the geometry of the points.
For example,
let's suppose that I'm on some plane.
All my points are on a plane.
Here's my equation of a plane.
So, all my points, X, Y,
and Z sa satisfy this.
Remember, we showed this before when
were mapping everything on a plane and
saying how it would've moved.
We ended up with a 3 by 3 matrix,
but it was a homogeneous system, so
we could scale it any way we wanted.
So if we wanted to, we could set
one of those elements to a 1,
and then we only had to solve for
the other eight.
There were eight unknowns, so therefore
we needed how many points, Megan?
How many points?
How many point?
Four points.
Here is the, the equation,
using just the X Y values,
and you'll see, a1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, eight point, eight unknowns, four
points needed, so when it's on a plane.
Now, if it, plane is very,
very far away, what does that mean?
Well, what it means is if the difference
in the distance on the plane is small,
compared to the distance from
the plane to the camera.
You can show that this is
the simplified model, right?
It's just six unknowns,
otherwise know as an affine transform.
This is one of the reasons that
affine transforms are used so much.
When things are on a plane,
on a wall, on the floor, even on maybe,
front of a body, for awhile.
Mine used to be more
planar than it is now.
For small amounts of motion,
you can think of this being as
a plane that's relatively far away.
And what that means is that this,
that that plane will undergo
an affine transformation.